okay if people joining this livestream
these are some details of language
design hopefully relevant to the version
12 of language which is very much
closing now
okay so information how to document it
um okay let's take take a look I mean we
could have a gallery I suppose and we
could have a gallery in the maybe you
can show me this is in it's in is it in
the builds or is it only in them at
least the version of the build I have
the formatting not sure what's going on
there
yeah so if you open up the notes you
will see No well okay Wow
it seems diligent but um we've tried to
use the cell links to make it a little
easier to navigate so in principle if
you say I want information about data
been there's the cell link that will
take you to more details about data been
why on earth is the order here symbol
temporal data that's a totally random
order yeah I mean the the order right
now is this kind of random that's not
good enough I mean right as it says in
the agenda don't freak out this is this
is a rough draft okay okay okay fair
enough
okay so it's some more rational order
would be in right so so I mean one
possible idea to make this not quite so
long is to move these individual tables
to the relevant function rough pages and
you know predictor function I think that
makes more sense I mean I think that's
what I would do here let's take a look
at predictor function for example
yeah I think you should say
informational predictor function gives
information on the predictor function
the following things are supported so
long as you give the generic cases like
this so the point is you can say of
information of a predictor function ,
you know wherever the thing is for a
predictor function down here comma
feature types so in other words if I
said something like predict um no what I
do table n arrow N squared and up to ten
so that will give me a predictor
function hopefully and now I say
information of percent okay and if I say
information of percent sixty comma
properties why this is auto completing
in a grotesque way I have no idea yeah
I'm not sure I'll check with Tom about
it also this just produced a raft of
self test errors yeah I was noticing
some notebook objects errors with
yesterday's build it might be related
but it's I think I think it's more
useful to have the information in the
yeah with the function itself okay okay
I probably should be the last entry last
thing most cases what was the last thing
with the foot in the function itself
let's take a look like predictor
function
you know I think something is going
wrong here look something is going wrong
with the generation of these thumbnails
that thumbnail isn't complete see that
yeah that's because they're not
automatically generated so basically
once per release Brian goes through and
regenerates them okay okay
is data set one of the things that
information works on it isn't right now
I mean information could wrap data set
but I think it could yeah I think
they'll be quite useful it end up being
just kind of a different presentation
for it I mean information is accepted in
data set and will turn you know you
could do data set of in 60 and it would
or 61 and it would turn it into a data
set format I'm not sure about no no
useful why no but I mean I think um
right I mean I would think that data
information of data set would give you
some sort of summary about the data set
not just I agree absolutely yes never
know it was just asking this font is
wrong you know that right yeah we were
making some tweaks ahead of the
conference to get a couple of things put
together okay so what was full data set
just click just does that rather than
that's what we had done for now rather
than having the I mean a lot of these
entities are gonna end up with this
hundreds of properties and rather than
putting them all on information just
make sure these fonts get fixed okay
okay and likewise that font isn't right
either yeah I'll check in tomorrow it's
only wait bottom line here is it's going
to the documentation is going to go in
with the individual functions and
anything you were just saying about data
set which sounded wrong to me anyway
isn't it needs to be in the general
documentation for information except it
shouldn't be there because it doesn't
seem right yeah I think predict
function in classifier function are
going a slightly different route because
of the way they were hooked up but I'll
take a look at that well no I'm saying
should data set of information put the
information in information into a data
set or not I think so I mean it would
essentially just graph it fun but then
information of data set does something
completely different
yeah okay
okay that font is wrong again right and
if that was what we SPECT the spec is
wrong I mean I think that's pretty much
the font I know I think it's just not
doesn't look right okay um can maybe we
can just very quickly get Jeremy Davis
and he should be here oh he's here
so I do hello Heidi okay can you send us
a mock-up of what the point you expect
is okay great okay okay you know I
wonder whether through some kind of um
not quite placebo effect whether people
can catch some virus even remotely
because they hear somebody else coughing
and somehow that changes their response
to their immune system which then lets a
virus a local virus in who knows you
mean sort of like yawning
yes right that that's contagious yes or
coughing at a performance I don't have
exactly the same example but it would
follow what we're doing here wouldn't it
I think so
yes I think so yeah I mean that looks
better
we just need to avoid this basically you
know typed input type font right that's
the I forget what it's called but the
code font right definitely not the code
font right you understand Heidi
absolutely okay all right okay so
there's just something wrong there so
who is the person to fix this I'll fix
it I'll double check with Heidi and what
the appropriate family is it looks like
this style we're using there it doesn't
explicitly give the font so it's falling
back to the code
okay okay fine okay
okay right so this is feedback we've
gotten from several internal and
external users right so with the old
question mark you would immediately have
a documentation link via that little
Chevron at the end which is good right
and now we don't so well so why don't we
have an I you know let's use the raft
metaphor and put a circle die in here or
a chevron chevron is possibility - okay
and so right when you open it up there's
a documentation guy do we remove that or
do we just which documentation guy so if
I say information of plot right what the
heck is that those are the options which
is another well this is really
weird-looking that should certainly have
Chevron's local greater than greater
than web greater than greater than okay
first point we just thinks I don't think
we want to say local and web I think
what we want to do it's just have an eye
up here which that would go to the local
what's that yes and in this version I
mean in the obvious in the cloud it goes
to the cloud it's a web right yeah
I would argue that documentation should
probably be the top of this of this list
of things here it's really a different
category of thing and I would I would go
documentation options attributes and
full and then full name we have
especially move documentation to be the
top right there is that in the close
state the it's just above the fold
that's possible I think the main trick
there since we have the different
backgrounds I feel like it might be a
little jarring to have just just having
an eye up here okay okay and in fact
that's closer to where you were just
typing so in fact in some sense it's
better okay right so we've gotten from a
few people or the father's being right
so you say information and attributes I
want to know if it's pulled off and I
can't because it's hidden there but we
have all this white space to the right
so I think we're probably way too
aggressive yes I agree with you you
might as well use a few more and I also
don't know why we protected was moved to
the front
that's just seems completely nonsense II
wrong here we moved it to the front a
that some of the spacing has changed
here but we moved it in the front
because when we wanted if it was in the
collapse form and read protected you to
see that it was reproductive so that's
why it's not showing definitions but I
think that's irrelevant nobody's gonna
understand that yeah just alphabetize
those okay if they're just three of them
just put them out there and this
shouldn't stay saying dot dot three
totals right when you open it it should
just list them all
if there's a dot dot dot it's at the
bottom mm-hmm I think I mean yeah III
yes I'm a bit more ambivalent about
having the total fare because when you
open that up it might still be nice to
remember oh I'm looking at a column of
63 things yeah I agree with you but then
why isn't it at the bottom oh I see yeah
that would work I mean they could go
under the options potentially I mean on
the left-hand side there yes where the
opener is I mean should it be the
openers in an obscure place honestly all
of these things people will figure out
who is wondering if you know if we
wanted to move the opener to the left
column with the options so that it lines
up better with when you open up the app
yeah I understand where it says options
greater than you I don't know it's not a
terrible idea it's certainly a bit weird
here where you've got the indent there
associated with the day with that opener
it seems wrong well because that weird
opener probably got lots of weird code
to just make that happen
it's a opener view with a custom icon
there I mean originally we modelled it
off of what was in system information
but that has left aligned columns I mean
the opener is to the left of the the
property name and everything explodes
below it but that when we shifted over
the design we wanted it to be closer to
the the list of options or the list of
elements but I do think you know it
doesn't need to be taking up space on
the first
in the air right so listen I agree let's
try and make ID could you make a mock-up
of what this would look like where
there's a greater than sign after the
attributes and after the options yeah
got it
so moving it over to the left do you
understand what I'm saying Heidi fine
after the option like you're moving the
greater than sign from the right hand
side here to the left hand side so it
says options greater than right when you
press that opener then this right hand
side will open see what I'm saying not
really yes before the colon
do we throw the : away then yeah I would
say it's probably in instead of the : oh
that's gonna look terrible right but I
think it would be weird if there's
something yeah by the way the point made
on the livestream
this should all be clickable this whole
bottom bar should be clickable you
shouldn't have to hit the caret okay
yeah that should be easy to do okay do
we need to get Jeremy to get an idea
about another idea about this where the
opener should be that's okay let's see
worry what this is the same thing I
don't know somewhat what do you what are
you showing us here okay okay okay so
he's asking why aren't possible the
default values showing the options
because we don't have that information
very cleanly it's used for autocomplete
to some extent but many of these things
you can feed it an arbitrary expression
another suggestion when there 163
options maybe it's more sensible to put
them in a scorable pane any thoughts
about that I don't think that's correct
i I never liked scorable panes it's just
a question and I mean you know the whole
page is scrollable just scroll it yeah
[Music]
we have a super long expression that
can't be right or something that can't
line break and we might create a
horizontally scrollable pane but that
doesn't make any sense to me what I just
did because what do you do with
attribute in that case what did you do
the same thing same thing yes yes yes
yes yes yes okay
so show the other state also I think
this actually looks better than I
expected it to really still it's a bit
more what's that alignment point isn't
aligned with system obviously needs to
be right I mean the other possibility
for like options and attributes is not
to use a scrollable pain but to do multi
column to the extent that it's possible
now I wouldn't I would not bother
I think that's overly precious and I
think it's gonna be confusing I think
the only issue is with this
the little opener is next to the 63
total you know yeah it's another
possibility someone on the livestream is
correctly pointing out that having this
microscopic click target but I mean the
whole options thing can be clickable so
it's not such a microscopic target so
eta the downside was putting the opener
after the 63 total is that when you open
it and where does it go
yeah it's wrong you can't do that it's
got to stay in the same place can you
refresh it yes I don't think that looks
bad I mean except you're going to get
rid of these when you when you open you
ought to get rid of those and also they
should be in gray the dot dot no 63
total should be in gray if Lizzie gray
yeah the dot dot doesn't look great to
me well I can't tell that over zoom but
the 63 total certainly has Jeremy just
join us yes okay so we're talking about
how to deal with this was the original
form here with a great colon and then
the greater than sign proposing this
okay yeah I suppose it's a little weird
to lose the : just because there's an
arrow there but I see why you need to do
we need the Coleman at all I mean
most guy without ya without see much
better without ok that somebody on the
livestream is suggesting make the 63
total the opener that won't work because
it moves and also when you press it
it'll be gone
you need a predictable place to click
but then so the idea would be the whole
options greater than would be clickable
right yeah and this would also be
clickable I think this will work i
refresh
it's okay I mean you should have the 63
total or whatever there and by the way
in this documentation surely you should
have some separator between the local
and web either a cent a dot or a
vertical bar
just read local web I'd never seen that
before today
okay um okay so we're going
documentation options attributes full
name correct yeah with the definitions
before that for functions that do have
them exposed so if I write a function
that has the D but then it won't have
documentation if it has definitions or
would have yes it will have
documentation won't it it's possible I
mean okay then then put definitions
after documentation okay if it has both
okay all right to me on to the next
thing
um wasting alone a lot presumably a
vertical scale when contexts are closed
yeah well that's clearly wrong Heidi do
you want to comment on that is this is a
scrunchy of spec or not no no okay a ton
of space just huge
well could you open up a few just
because it probably doesn't look as bad
open is that still too much Heidi big
eye does look like it's way design is on
that first link in the chat that we
looked at earlier yeah that does seem
like it's it just seems wrong so yeah so
I think yeah if you open first by the
way there's no hover on this and there
should be a hover on these things that
have openness there should be a hover
okay makes sense guys Heidi Nick you
know make sense okay yeah I was making
some tweaks to it at the last minute to
try and fix some of the spacing in the
open state and I think we just lost
track of we were using source code is
that gonna be wrong for the function
name we were previously and then we
changed away from it in the last spec
the I think you weren't in that meeting
Heidi but yeah we went back to source
and okay although the context names
aren't in source and that looks like
Ariel they don't
that wonderful yeah I think it's just a
bug it's yeah it looks like the the
style is just missing that declaration
so it's falling back okay all right
onward
are those string patterns right so names
and the old information support string
patterns and regular expressions I think
Nick may have fixed the missing of
string patterns so information that the
question is whether information I'd no
idea that it supported some of those
things but I mean information of plot um
star that seemed to work
yep but if you did plot you know tilde
tilde you know blank sequence and we've
lost that and that's something that used
to work right if you names with that
that should give you a list of things
right I understand that should work
right and it's not documented I think
that's probably a documentation but yes
I agree
well whatever yeah yeah I think I think
the case for string expressions pretty
clear the question about blank sequence
or regular expression is whether we want
information to be looking up symbol
names or potentially giving information
about either the pattern or the regular
expression yeah I agree I think that
this is not an obvious case I think
string the string name you know plot
star that should just work string
patterns should work
I mean string patterns as in that sense
a string that is a pattern yeah right
should work and similarly this string
expression form like this should work
okay
I wouldn't necessarily make the explicit
symbolic regular expression work at this
time
I could imagine we'll need F for
something else for words the difference
between a string expression in a regular
expression
it's syntactically different not really
because every regular regular I know I
know matically it's the same right
semantically it's exactly the same but
my point is that we can distinguish it
here right
we can distinguish that from regular
expression of this we don't have to
support we don't have to make the two
things work the same way and I don't
think we should right now maybe we will
later but I think we shouldn't do that
right now because we may need
information of a regular expression to
do something make sense yeah I I'm just
not understanding because because you
could make the same argument had you
used the full form of string expression
instead of saying tilde tilde something
rather yes yeah but I don't think it's
correct because I think I look it may
very well be we don't need to use
information regular expression for
anything in which case in the next
version we can change this to work in
the same way as it does with the naked
string okay I just think it is not
necessary to support this and I don't
think we should support it initially
just in case we need to mean something
different names if names does this right
now names should go on doing it but
you're saying it isn't documented so
don't document that case well actually
what it did is very weird what did it
just do that well you you that was a
correct regular expression you said
followed by any number including zero of
ELLs yeah okay fine
yep but we never documented this you're
saying we did not we didn't document the
fact that I worked with the string
expressions either really yes well I've
known that for 30 years but but Tim I
never tried using it with legs or
expression oh maybe I'm wrong maybe we
should just have this we should just
document it and not allow the
possibility of information of a regular
expression to do something that's my
inclination as well
all right let's let's do that I guess
[Music]
fine that may be a use for verbatim or
something or inactive or it could do
that verbatim if we needed to if we
needed to back out I suppose we could do
that all right okay I think that was it
for that section
okay so the graphic design and other
people are related to information can
depart all right right bye Thanks
alright so I started annotating
everything and then I decided okay this
is ridiculous and you'll find a whole
bunch of tentative notes where I
basically holistically rewrite all the
notes forget and so this is remind me
what the context of this is so the
context is that we added a new option
and I was looking at you know the
existing documentation and decided it it
just it's you know people have added
things random gunk random gunk and you
know so we should just rewrite it and
make it make sense okay what is group
slash I don't understand that so if
right so if you it's in its you have to
read the note above it right so if you
do a package back you know group
backtick package which i think is
basically how we were documenting this
okay I just don't like the name group
directory yes then let's call it that
okay I mean I would say done and let's
not commit that it's a package for
goodness sake well I guess it has to be
a package well or file we could just
call it file well no it's not look at
table it's not a file in most cases you
know and that's why I'm not necessarily
a fan of directory because the idea is
that you've got a hierarchical package
right so you've got the base name of the
package and then something more specific
with the back to convert what we call in
polymer specific to then call it puff we
could call it package backtick sub
package okay let's understand what
you're talking about here so the first
thing is a table that says it searches
for wait a minute what name is I'm very
confused
if you say let's unless their name so
depends on what name is that's the whole
point
the name is of the form can't expect
except context what if it's just to the
form context backtick what do you mean
I'm sorry
right so the point is that you know
except for last context leading context
are assumed to be defining a directory
structure and then the final sub context
is defining the package to look up which
may be in any of several different forms
all right okay so look documentation
wise I think the thing to do is first
have a table that says basically to just
say process this name right processes
name to find the file to read okay
I mean roughly I'll just write something
for a name
something like given than the name well
I'm writing it poorly and I'm not sure
that we want to use the term package
here given the name package get will
search for for the following basically
and then you give it the MX file with
this the bad the other well no because
I'm saying I think that what it should
have is a table before you get to the
sub table here you should have a first
table that just lists without the sub
package business
well that which would be that entire
table just without the group yes exactly
well let me say right right so so but
but Steven my point is this is where we
want to be rewriting I don't think we
want to be rewriting the old stuff do I
agree I agree I agree it's no I can
delete that but I'm just saying okay so
you're saying what where are you
restarting well with the first tentative
note is where I'm restarting okay so all
of this is going away yes everything yep
okay all right okay including get of
local object and things that's a
different thing yeah I see you're
putting them at the bottom that okay
I was reordering so many of them it just
made sense
yeah all right all right fine okay so
what I'm suggesting is right so if you
want to break this into two notes where
for a name of the form context backtick
and then have context you know no group
slash just context context context right
right so what I'm suggesting then for a
name of the form context backtick yeah I
like this then this just becomes context
yeah and you could write I can fix the
remaining guys and then we have a second
note for context back to sub context yes
the process will be you know what will
search for will use the name of the form
sub context backtick context no well
it's it's now path backtick context AC
get will search for files of the form
path slash context dot dot that roughly
right
that's roughly okay we can fix the fix
it more exactly if name is the name of
the file you know
yeah okay god that's totally weird I
didn't even know you could get to that
page anymore
I think we should list out or what they
I mean I think we should list out
something here that's really hostile to
go that looks pretty good
okay all right should we go on to the
next thing
sure so one other comment today is that
presumably that table should be added to
the documentation for fine file at the
same time once that gets cleaned up okay
yes relations example between yet and
fine file pointing out that they use the
same resolution okay character encoding
right so this is in particular about
Unicode which was which is never a
character encoding anyway and it's quite
quite crazy here exactly and so we
listed I mean I we need that we need to
include it at least initially I know
maybe there are ways around this but I
think we do want it because they're
places where like to cares where you
need it but what it means varies from
functions of function so I think rather
than sort of being here in the and this
particularly particular interpretation I
think is actually only true in export in
the export family of functions it's not
true when you're writing oh yeah so so
I've got another suggestion is it the
case should it not be a symbolic form
instead of Unicode I mean if it was like
automatic or all or something like this
what does that not work
I mean character encoding explain to me
what Unicode actually is what what the
unicode character encoding actually is
okay so
on functions of varies from function to
function in to character code and from
character code it means map between
characters and raw Unicode code points
so integers between 0 and 1 million
something or other that's extremely
confusing that becomes an 8 ok 950 is a
Zeta ok fine ok so there's a Zeta now if
I say from character code of that comic
character encoding arrow it's just it's
just an argument that's not an option
ok the string unicode there you'll get
the same thing right but if I say Zapf
dingbats I'll get garbage no I don't get
why doesn't it give an error if Zacks if
it's if it's bigger than the Zapf
dingbats size it should front character
code should surely give an error in that
case I'm sure that would break many
things so yes decision to be sort of as
nice as you can many years ago and I
don't know what would be the
consequences of changing that maybe we
should investigate but not for the 1200
releases exactly definitely not for 12
I'm happy to investigate utf-8 would
have given a message it would have given
the message and then it would have
fallen back to you
oh it didn't give it I guess it just got
confused because it was so big if you
give it something invalid like fine try
150 instead of 10,000 yeah right so yes
I think I don't know exactly what it's
doing it's it's it's issuing the message
and then doing
the best that I can which is probably
treating it as the peasant yes iso
8859-1 basically right yeah I know what
it's if you get an invalid byte sequence
it will complain and this is only
because with you know utf-8 you can
actually tell whether a sequence of
bytes is valid or not and I suppose once
you get above a byte then it's just
ignoring right because it's not a utf-8
not plausibly utf-8 Bret okay so explain
to me Unicode here right so unicode is
basically the default argument so yes
right yeah but I mean yes okay right I
understand it's it's the R or encoding
it's it's the thing that is in some
sense actually I have no idea you know
we could imagine something many of these
these encodings here happen to be 8-bit
encodings right right but they don't
necessarily have to be 8-bit encodings I
don't even know whether they are always
a present coding so I mean you see
Compiegne a prett encoding no it's a
variable length eight or sixteen what
were that shift just that's another
crazy one
right yeah same thing okay right so we
use those things anymore I think there
is a small but nonzero usage of it East
Asia as a dual switch to Unicode yeah I
mean utf-8 is now a very large
percentage of what's out there
yes and even things like utf-16 and
utf-32 are which we which are actually
character encodings that should be here
somewhere okay so we should add those to
this table
right well we don't have those yet okay
okay but those are things whose target
is 16 bits and so on right okay so okay
so what's your point about documenting
Unicode right so my point is and similar
sorts of functions it basically means
you know mapped between integers you
know 21 bit integers and and characters
in export what it means is use what-what
would have been called UCS tubes
so basically big-endian UCS - so 2 bytes
per character big-endian you use it as a
as raw on the raw output stream what it
means is use one byte if you're less
than 250 256 use 2 bytes if you're again
let me make a suggestion why don't we
break this into multiple louvered
whatever it was UCS - whatever you're
calling it why don't we have that be a
character encoding here and have that be
the thing that's used for export and
then the default case for from character
code which is the one argument form
barely needs to be named though as we
split unicode we perhaps deprecated the
name unicode and replace it with these
various UCS whatever you called it
[Music]
so so I agree that right okay I'm not
sure we want to completely absolutely
unicode well we don't have to we don't
have to but I mean does it mean yes and
I agree that certainly export can't
continue what it's doing now that we
support things beyond the multilingual
plane yeah well also but I mean the big
endian little-endian thing being able to
parameterize that for export seems
highly useful right and they know it
does already I'm pretty sure that's true
but I'd have to double-check that
actually ignored on in export does does
from character code take a bite order
option I don't think so because it's
just taking integers right in its and
sure is an integer it doesn't care how
it's encoded correct it's only like read
binary binary read you know binary
reading important things that care about
the encoding order correct okay right so
for example math link streams don't care
because they're always just using
mething to transport the actual
characters you know when you're directly
writing I understand to somebody else is
external you know externally handleable
file right okay so what do we remain to
figure out what this Unicode thing but
why don't we think through but not here
what it means to have to just change the
name of the one in an import and export
and in the case of character encoding we
can have it be for now the the sort of
the name that means just turn it into
that integer right but I agree with it
we're gonna need the UCS whatever it was
UCS to UCS to
uh you know encoding listed in the Dalek
character encoding list here yep right I
guess so right so do do we just change
the description here I was thinking
maybe we split Unicode out from this
table and just have a note about Unicode
I think we leave it in here and we could
say paren for yeah we just leave it um
the with the plus one biting code we
just say something like um I guess the
other point is right it's no longer 16
bits right it's now 21 bit right so I
think we just say I what what is the
correct description for here well that
sort of it right it depends on what
function is consuming it but the closest
I guess the closest would be raw 21 bit
Unicode code points if we wanted to do
that alright okay
but why is it 21 bit I mean look you're
right let's leave it out of this table
let's leave it as a thing that still
works but let's put in ucs-2 and
whatever else is relevant in this table
okay and then the one argument form we
just have to say the one argument form
for two character code we have two
independently document that I think we
already do why does this note where is
the raft the raft is gone
oh boy I don't know whose project
managing okay so yes another way yeah I
know
you
the character with integer code blah
blah blah
all right so you see there's a modified
involved there where it's now 1 million
and change instead of 65535 that's cool
right and actually I also mean I also
need to update a note on dollar
character encoding about the fact that
there's now a backslash pipe in addition
to a backslash : what does backslash
pike mean that's four six six six hex
digits unicode instead of four hex
digits because well most regards outside
of the basic multilingual plane is 21
bits sufficient for everything that
people have currently encoded I thought
it was went to 32 bits no it's not 23
bytes yeah and they're making emojis
Yeah right we might run out but right
well they might have to register a you
know one of those custom emojis for
every human on the planet yes but I
think treaty unicode has a limit on how
many they are going to allow for total
characters oh my god I see I see some
tremendous you know I don't even know
where you go to appeal a I mean I
remember when Unicode was first being
developed and Korea had all kinds of
issues about whether they were gonna
have enough code points um and there
were some other countries that didn't
make it into the into the you know plain
zero Unicode um but okay I don't even
know what some actual 439 137,000 439
characters 1.1 million so I guess they
feel like they have really so
I went up from the sixty four sixty
thousand to one huh
140 thousand I thought they'd added like
you know Babylonian canal form and stuff
like this that didn't take up very much
guess not and if you think about it I
mean how many Babylonians in their form
I mean let's even say that's a thousand
yeah oh no it's nothing right so
basically the world is being you know
it's being deluged in emojis yes the
like people with very small language
communities their characters are being
delayed because of the craze over emoji
and yeah I think I remember seeing that
yeah well there was this kid at the
summit campus here who did this mapping
between sentiments of Twitter of tweets
and the emoji they contained to find out
which emoji were the happiest and
saddest emoji that was um yeah there's
there's it's how we're going back to
some kind of hieroglyphic form okay
let's go back to the failure function
here so what's the issue with failure
here listen it's this an urgent thing
right now neither of these is urgent so
and since we're both sick if you want to
wrap up I think we should wrap up um I
do want to comment that delete missing
so he's asking about delete failure
historic missing I I had not realized
that delete missing so here's an
interesting case of delete missing okay
so let's say we have and say missing
oops
okay so if we do this right we know what
delete missing is gonna do right now
let's say we do this okay so I claim
that there is a worthwhile default
operation here that delete missing
should delete so delete missing will do
nothing here right I claim that it
should delete every first level item
that contains well how many levels
[Music]
okay well let's but let's see what this
does because I don't think if I go down
to level two here yeah it's gonna do
that right and so one comma two okay the
question is should it do that by default
if this point probably not for backward
compatibility right and I guess I mean
my preference would be that we had
another you know a second delete missing
function that has that behavior this is
not for this meeting let's figure out
just one comment I think this may depend
on the function it's adding for example
if we find the lead missing acting on G
opposition obviously injure position has
to do this because we cannot just remove
the latitude and leave a longitude or
int I'm serious we cannot just leave one
value of the term but in the array I
think this is doing the right thing
right now okay fair enough
well the let's check that it does the
right thing for to your positions and so
on right it's not even implemented but
but once I implemented it I should do
that
it removes the whole point okay so Jose
you're saying you see you're gonna give
your teacher to leave missing how to
work directly on geo position yeah I see
some yeah no that's to gulp it other has
to kill the whole geo position or not it
can't leave an incorrect structure X
right no it's correct right but if
there's a partial missing what is the
question is what is sort it's not you
know I would I would claim it's not a
priori obvious that if you have a list
of the list of things that you should
consider them independent vectors yeah I
get it you're right a time you're right
for hoovsies consideration even within
geo position you know so if you have
latitude and longitude and the elevation
is missing
I mean this case this case you will have
already generated a message so it's a
pretty pathological case yes but so so
yes we have discussed in other times
whether we should allow this situation
and just let other functions avoid that
point I'm thinking of the case in which
there we have an array of points so our
list of points not a single point
because in this case well you're saying
delete missing if there's a if you do it
okay it will generate an error but then
not necessarily I mean missing is not
supported into your position right now
we could support it and then not guys I
mean and like in geogrid position that
sort of thing arises naturally right yes
okay have points all around the world
and you use a projection that only shows
one hemisphere this is a discussion of
of the back in error or some things of
that is about to leech failure and I
don't think that there's a I don't think
that makes as much sense I mean if you
get if you have a list of what we do not
have a delete failure that's just
whether we should I don't think that's
such a common cases delete missing maybe
I'm wrong that that you go and do you
know you try and connect to a bunch of
see missing doesn't get an error
messages whereas failure tends to I
think right I mean I guess I guess my
initial instinct is that if you have
failure you have an actual error
condition yes and if all you want to do
is you
the league failed you know removed a
failure and and dollar fails then you
can use delete if you really meet to
where as missing crisis but you know
maybe you need to clean them all right
I agree okay I'll just say that there
are looks like a fair number of cases in
the source code where people have done
delete cases of what I'm a dollar failed
okay all right
a comment from the livestream suggests
that chicken curry is good for colds all
right
thanks all yep okay see you bye